[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
welcome back to the breakthrough baby
hey it's a friday let's let's all break
out a quick little friday scream
that's beautiful yes this is the break
room
our daily live show that covers all the
nerd news you need to know live right
here from our very own break room at
nrhq in a secret location that no matter
how hard you try you will never find i
can't find it happening nowhere near
burping california no don't even know
15 12 19 48 16 i'm gonna keep going with
digital so many digits you walk around
long enough you'll hear screams
that's the trick if it's friday and you
walk around you might hear a scream
uh yes this is the break room we got a
lot to talk about today uh including
thor premiered hey the movie's coming
out that's that's always good news uh
stranger things is done making you happy
uh and we got some mad max news coming
up and we have got to talk about what
they've done to my baby boy the mcu
timeline they murdered my boy boy
but i'm not the only one here today
despite my excessive amount of talking
so far we've got a great panel on the
show today with me as shared equally
over across the table we've got coy
jondro i'm so excited to be here on a
friday my first friday you got it it's a
different energy it's a whole thing oh
you have to get it out very differently
around here yeah be happy uh some of us
aren't here yeah
oh yeah you'll notice the table is clear
of cups except for this one who knows
what's in this one uh and the candy
moonshine the canister i mean that would
be the the least
problematic now i know on this show
we also have jessica clements back on
the show today of course if you watch
the latest episode of the boys you know
what's in that cup oh you know
yeah
we we the boys underground will be up on
the channel any moment now and there
were so many bodily fluids on this
episode what an episode speaking of
bodily fluids we got an event sting
chock full of bodily fluids hey clip it
clip it can we clip that
out no proof no proof let's clip that
out uh it's friday we're having a great
time already and we hope you're having a
great time in the chat hey do me a favor
and hit that like button right now do it
just do it uh the swear jar is gone guys
we'll curse today
i can't do it it's not an impression
we'll swear all we want today but we do
have a chat redemption okay don't think
you got off scot-free and the chat
redemption you'll notice this clear cup
in this halloween bucket both timely
both both right here uh we're doing a
cup of inspiration today for every
hundred dollars in the chat uh that we
get for super chats we're gonna we're
gonna read an inspirational quote uh in
the style of a character so we got
quotes we got characters okay uh if we
hit 100 we'll pop off a couple if we get
to 200 we'll do a little more and maybe
they'll get spicier who knows who knows
let's get to 100 first and then we'll
negotiate okay uh uh so that's our
redemption today we can say
any curses we want whatever we want
i can't sorry not yet not yet it's
pressure there's a lot of pressure to do
it uh so we got a great show so much to
talk about but first
headlines
there it is rest in peace hold progress
so dramatic
our first headline james gunn tweets it
was not a bad idea to bring harley quinn
back for another project when someone
asked about it million dollar idea
did he want a headline anyone think for
a second we would never see harley quinn
again the margot robbie not the lady
gaga
i like what she does with it he took
over suicide squad he's doing peacemaker
maybe another show
i think we should get another bird to
pray like
thank you i love birthdays i really
think tonally it was a great like sister
sequel to joel schumacher's batman like
that gotham was so lush and interesting
and it made it the campiness that a lot
of people wanted you and mcgregor
amongst the best comic villains out
there i really i think it's one of the i
think in 10 years we'll look back and
like this bird's a prey joint not too
shabby print it put it on nft that's the
headline there it is
next headline hey the stranger things
creators the duffer brothers have begun
warning fans that the end of uh stranger
things season four will not have a happy
ending okay they're tired of you loving
these characters they're gonna die okay
they mentioned that this is a darker
season and the kids aren't kids anymore
they're kind of kids
put your money where your mouth is and
kill one of them already
give you calories
what's funny is i know you wrote it for
him because i was walking out last time
i was like jolly discussing stranger
things he was like everything
like it was just such a hey we all love
stranger things right i'm so tired of
strangers oh man well season three was
so comparatively joyous are you guys
watching am i alone on the stranger
things i like stranger things stranger
things three the third stranger things
was actually like my least favorite and
that joy i didn't it was like because i
think it's my least favorite because of
billy i was like
i hate billy and i hate that people love
him and he is completely wholeheartedly
all racists mullet was so lush it was
just so lush his hair and she's a red
power ranger so we're all blinded it
just inspired so many times jason's my
red power ranger okay i'm an old man is
that the one that killed his roommate he
was the very first one with the sword
did one kill there was a sword
actually
not jason david frank who's lovely okay
i'm sorry i get my murderer we've
derailed
which power ranger is the biggest
murderer to you oh the yellow one i'm
gonna have to fight you oh not anyone
but the yellow one not the other one
this is a friday show
yeah i gave up on stranger things when
they never brought back barb
oh
i mean
she's kind of living it up in a hell
hole
aren't we all
aren't we off oh friday everybody
uh next headline
[Music]
next headline warner brothers released a
new synopsis for mad max furiosa the
prequel i can't wait to see here's the
synopsis stick with me as the world fell
young furiosas snatched from the green
place of many mothers and falls into the
hands of a great biker horde led by the
warlord dementis sweeping through the
wasteland they come across the citadel
presided over by the immortan joe with
the two tyrants war for dominance
while the two tyrants wore for dominance
furiosa must survive many trials as she
puts together the means to find her way
home
sounds fun the green place of many
mothers is where i was last night a
doink
sounds like a fun movie we're all
excited for it i mean the cast is crazy
like like hemsworth and anya taylor joy
george miller like that guy came out of
us being 70. yeah come give us one of
the best action movies of all time so
something that you will get looking for
i'm looking for a furious the first
thing i'm looking for i broke the first
theater rule i'm chewing gum and i
haven't stopped
live chat tell us if that's real or not
we need a doctor yeah live chat
someone give us data please please
please hey next headline we like bad max
i'm moving
it could uh next headline tycho what tt
mentioned there was a part of him that
wanted jane foster in ragnarok uh and
they he knew for sure he wanted to bring
her back he was talking about this last
night at the premiere i believe we have
a clip of it if we can run that it was
something that you know it was part of
the comic run by jason aaron and it was
something that we were always in love
with
when i was working on ragnarok we were
always talking about how cool that was
and you know there was part of me on on
ragnarok who really wished that you know
that natalie could have been part of
that and then when they said look we
want to bring her back
it all just made sense and you know we
were like she's got to be mighty thor
she's now going to take the hammer and
that character has got to evolve and
she's got to be a hero too
god i love that voice
his
voice
that suit makes him look like
beetlejuice and he's so full that's so
funny he was he was beautiful yeah yeah
he's talking about that and we know that
he was reading the comics that inspired
uh thor love and thunder while he was
filming thor ragnarok which is funny for
him to say like oh i wish he could have
been in that but that means he was like
they're filming it and he's reading the
comics and he's like oh
put her in there should i have called
like the house oh is it too late
i like to think that like when they gave
him the movie they're like so who do you
want and you know he's going through
names and he and they were like do you
want us to bring back nine he's like i
don't know who that is you know like
watch the old movies read six jason here
in comics she's like oh this is a great
idea uh but we're all glad she's back
right yeah
yeah
you
but the comic we can talk about which is
incredible you read that
yeah my thor is really sad and very good
and asadra beast art is some of the best
thor's ever been illustrated by jason
aaron one of the all-time great one of
the longest running if not longest
running i think him walter simonson tied
for first four writers of all time and
what it does is it both modernizes thor
odin some it also gives us a new thor
and i think the way without giving
anything away they were able to
modernize that further with the movie
coming soon is exceptional see more
importantly we got uh chad says gum
thing as a matthew yeah
yeah
yeah
love lucifer you put you poop pooper pop
either way you pop out gum poop out gum
as fast
uh we did also get a super chat from
ragnar slothbruck great name great super
chat ricardo medina jr the red ranger
from power rangers wild force stabbed
his roommate with a replica sword sounds
like a a working replica to me what a
yeah if it stabs
anything's a sword if you push hard
enough that's what the power would do
i hope the person made it but also what
a way to go that is just darkness
what a way to go uh yes send in those
super chats let's get to these
inspirational questions yeah try one
give it a taste okay no impressions
yeah yeah let's do it okay this is what
you'll get and let me tell you she's
only going to give up 50
yeah
not to have the questions i got the
joker oh that's a good one
because i want you to do the joker so it
has to be half the quote and half the
joker impression
focus on what they have to go through
people who succeed focus on what it
would feel like at the end oh it sounds
like it hurts it sounds like
no from the video game um injustice oh
okay i was just picturing him at like a
restaurant pulling out the like fortune
cookie like that's what i was hearing
was like him reading it so like hardly
across the table that was my experience
keep in mind that was 50
yeah
if we get to 100 bucks you'll get
another one if we get to 200 we'll do
fortune cookies rules and throw in bed
on the end
we do a few more super chats if we want
to do we do we want to do we want to
catch up with us
do one more super chat this is you're so
stoked i'm the only one that can like
barely read suave i see
up
yoda yoda suave yesterday was my
birthday and i would love to get a
belated roast from the break room crew
who's gonna roast it
june 23rd is the worst [ __ ] day to
have a birthday what a loser get born on
the 24th already
june that's what nine months ago was i
mean like october what were your parents
doing you were like a product of
halloween yeah you're so sorry these
characters when they conceived what a
weird choice how does that feel you
smell like firefly poop oh tasty very
specific delicious anything what would
be mean to them
we wanted to roast them look here
oh you're a piece of [ __ ]
that doesn't seem like that's too real
okay if i could crawl into a bunker and
die just from seeing your name on the
screen i would and i probably will
excuse me
oh you killed jessica she's going to the
bathroom
crawling under the bunker tommy's gone
i'm going to be the meanest person in
this oh cotter on our bad friday guys
everything's going wrong uh hey here's
another headline there's a thor a new
thor love and thunder clip that came out
that shows thor giving the guardian to
the galaxy and some blue people a very
inspiring speech let's take a look at
that clip
god of thunder king khan
you have finally joined our fight well
they say better late than not alone
this is very nice
as you know we used to live in a
peaceful all us
but in our gods were murdered murdered
and now our sacred temple has been left
unguarded and hope was dissolved to
control of its power it is our most
sacred shrine and it desecrates not for
long
king you can't
tell them what happened here today
tell us the time that four
drag tag motley crew misfit desperados
turn the tide in the battle and that's
their names in history the odds may be
against us but i'll tell you this for
free here we go this
and
here and now
whoa
that outfit is so good i literally went
and i had an audio reaction
i love the laser beam going through the
that uh star-lord's like still pumped up
about yeah uh thor cause we've seen him
be so negative on him all before and
even the promos it seems like he's like
over thor already he's always been over
thor we seem pretty jacked up in there
ooh jessica's
what i can what i can say without
getting on in trouble for having seen
the movie is that that outfit which you
dig is thunder strike based which is
this really 90s version of thor that was
like a world wrestler like wwf
so what's cool is they use the ultimates
comics for the first few thors where he
like doesn't know if he's actually a god
but they turned that into like an
existential crisis and now they use the
90s of thor to play with our current
nostalgia love for 80s stuff and so
they're able to like pick and choose the
greatest arcs and make that with just
visual cues for us comic fans i love
that that's fantastic i do without
getting in trouble aliens sounded like
christopher walken does he say like
oasis well yeah there's some great oasis
i love that stuff uh alien's too stunned
to speak so excited for this movie i'm
glad some people got to see it hey next
headline jamie alexander who plays lady
siffen thor teased a surprise come back
to thor love and thunder we knew she was
going to be in the movie she's on her
name's on the poster
so no surprise there but excited to see
her in the film
during the premiere she said yesterday i
don't know if you guys heard her say
this
i don't know why you wouldn't uh she
said quote i didn't have to train and
you'll see why we haven't seen her in
another thor movie since dark world but
she appeared in agents of oh that was
the end of the quote so i was missing
the end
i didn't have to train and you'll see
why take take that what you will of what
that means behind this gum it kind of
bums me out like i like seeing her kick
booty and it says to me that she's not
she's not fighting i know well we'll see
maybe she's just stayed in great shape
uh
jessica put in the script that we
haven't seen her since thor dark world
but we did see her on loki where she
kind of appeared as like a thing uh and
she was also an agent of shield when
they were like this is totally tidy
but she was an agent's shield when they
were like hey agents of shield matters
uh and then they build on that uh
so i've been renamed
oh
jessica
so as i've said jessica and my boys were
there or cory got together
eric boss was there too you cannot talk
about it did you see ladies
i did the funny thing so they the way
that the premiere worked is and you are
used to this i am not is a puzzle of a
maze of people yelling at you and
berating you don't go hurry no and the
movie doesn't start for like an hour and
a half they're just constantly rushing
people through and so they have this
barrier where you're going this way and
the people going this way are the
celebrities doing like little quick stop
pit stops at interviews and taking
pictures with fans and lady siff was
there and her giant bl like purple it
just looked like a giant purple dress
that was like with black gloves so you
couldn't see anything and i kept being
like who is that woman
it's weirder seeing the people in person
because you're like oh they look
familiar but i don't know what it is the
only person i spotted immediately
without you know it being natalie
portman was uh sean gunn
sean gunn was there and i was like
that's sean she was right behind me in
the like when you go and get like the
getty images and stuff like the the
stills so i was walking that line and
she was getting interviewed right behind
me and she is just like i she was almost
wonder woman yeah and i kept being like
that's a wonder woman like she's just so
striking as a human she was taking
pictures and signing autographs a lot
ladies so she was like
she was doing it the most um but also
chris hemsworth was taking a picture
with the little person dressed up like a
little girl dressed up as thor and i was
like oh and he kept being like okay look
at the camera and she would look away
and she was like look look at the camera
and she was like looking and i was like
i like that you just called a child a
little person
no i've only gone to the carnage one and
this one and the carnage one only made
me mad because every single person was
dressed up as spider-man and i was like
we know that he's not gonna be here
i was getting so mad there's so many
spider ones and i was like why are you
here as well we went to go see
multiverse venus there were so many
people that they were dressed up as
spider-man it's like just spider boys
just lots of hope we'll talk about that
in a minute why that doesn't make sense
you can't just dress up as spider-man
for everything
no jock straps
if you have a spider-man cosplay outfit
make sure you buy a dance belt or please
doctor or something yeah new dance belt
yeah
did you have fun for it being like it's
a bit that was a bigger one it was
really it was just gorgeous and i was
just i was more excited that my first
like marvel premiere was a thor movie
yeah like out of anything i was like
thor isn't like the first comics i run
to but i love what taika watiti does to
those films and i was just like every
person in this movie i am supporting and
i'm very happy about i love it so i'd
only met chris once before he had a cold
and he was still the manliest person i'd
ever encountered like him with a cold
was like greater than any person i'd met
and then last night he was at full power
and it's just it's flabbergasting that
the like we're the same species like
that man it's like seeing a chihuahua
and a great day and you're like oh those
are both dogs being around hemsworth is
like how does this person also be the
same genes as me yeah
he was made in a lab i heard that
to uh they didn't have the the premier
last night was completely uh green like
there was no carbon footprint yeah
because they had chris hemsworth riding
and like a motorcycle a bike a
stationary bike and powered the whole
theater
that's how we stay so lean yeah yeah
shut up yeah you animal yeah no shut up
shut up
it's only like three hours for him like
he just got there a little early prepped
us that's why we were on the carpet so
long because chris was charging
everything yeah so you both were there
you can't talk about the movie give me
three words just three words
for your
movie watching experience don't spoil
anything no give me three
words well you do that yeah yeah yeah
we did pass we did break down 100 thank
you for all the super chats we'll get to
those uh during the show we're going to
give you a little inspirational quote
pick a character so long uh
[Music]
stay away from those people who try to
disparage your ambitions it's not bad
small minds will always do that but
great minds will give you a feeling that
you can become great too that's actually
really good you were worried
no sorry sorry
is that tony stark any guesses in the
chat
than
we got a thanos in the chat not thanos
once you're here once you figure it out
it'll be like oh it wasn't bad tony
soprano was closed oh okay okay soprano
it was
kingpin oh
what are your three words um i'm gonna
say
can it does rock and roll count we'll
we'll take one for that or is that all
three
i was asking
rock and roll with hyphens
rock and roll
um punk
and
[Music]
family family
punk family
nothing says punk like the biggest movie
industry
the history of cinema that then says
punk i'm gonna go vibrant
cacophony
extravaganza extravaganza i'm making a
sentence okay vibrant coffee
extravaganza you want to do one real
fast oh i thought we each did one oh oh
do we do one at a time all right that
makes sense we'll give them two we'll
give it two two
hundred we'll really we'll do a bunch
okay two for now sounds good yeah oh i
can do this one
it is in your moments of decision that
your destiny is shaped
yeah wow
that was full till batman
okay let's get into this discussion
jessica yeah i got you talking software
yeah uh hit me on camera too baby
marvel just released their official
updated mcu timeline so it has
multiverse of madness and miss marble
along with some of the other new ones
like uh moon knight what have you let's
take a look at the timeline order switch
to camera one
and now no one help him plus right and
this is disney plus this is
this is like on disney plus when they're
like they have that playlist that's like
chronological order right yeah uh
of mcu movies if you want to watch them
in the order they happen like in in the
timeline so you would start with like
uh captain america then it goes to like
captain marvel blah blah blah blah they
want to fit in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness which is out now
uh well do you want incorrectly not over
the last few well here's yeah yeah the
last few and this is where it gets
screwy and i think they're wrong they're
they're definitely i don't know if
they're going to go back and change it
or if they're just going to
be mad we're going to be mad at them for
yeah
2023 start us here jessica 2023 where
you get avengers end game right yes
and then where do we go from there wait
why are you asking me oh you think you
know you want me to work through my my
timeline oh okay this and you already
set it up
oh okay perfect 2023 we have avengers
end game we have loki
i'm gonna go through them first and then
we can argue about why these are not
correct
we got what if uh right after what if is
one division right after one division is
falcon the winner soldier which we
knew didn't do this that makes sense
this makes sense yeah after the falcon
in the winter soldier is shang chi
and the legends of the temple
and the lord of the rings
i was like this is lord of the rings
well you to throw the ten rings in the
mortar the whole time the ten rings need
to get in there and then we go down and
this way yeah no we come here and then
this is the big five eternals and then
we have a turtle
after shanxi
but then we have doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness yeah completely
wrong yes then we have hawkeye
moon knight and miss marvel yeah yeah
yeah okay
and there's an addition we gotta grab
that edition because that's another oh
yeah
that's a doctor strange level foible in
my opinion yeah okay this is disney plus
they don't have do you want me to bring
it but they claim it goes
so we have spiderman no way home which
we know like far from home right yeah
which we know
uh happens before yeah
this right yes also before hawkeye but
where'd they put it but they claimed
yeah it's not on their list because it's
not on disney plus yeah yeah they
haven't like put it on there so like we
know that this because it ends at
christmas time this happens at christmas
time so this happens uh uh if we say
like 2024 is here okay
and this is 2025
better on this end because i would argue
the the spidey shows the problem here
like the biggest problem yeah yeah
the problem is right
so oh yeah yeah the biggest problem is
internals also scrolling their problems
really quick
but no so you can go off in internals
right they have uh
it happens in 2023. it happens like
after
um
the events of endgame we don't know
exactly when but it's in 2023 so it
needs to be like up here somewhere right
the thing which is this is the confusing
part why i hope they're going to go back
and
retcon or whatever the hell they're
doing is because they should know about
these people yeah yeah sorry daschle
they should know about these people so
there's no reason why this one should be
behind this one and the biggest issue of
all right yeah yeah is that
spoilers for the movie that just got on
disney plus
there's a conversation here that mounts
this man this
very much here which throws off this
here so really this is at best here this
is kind of out of time and this is
literally out of it somewhere i am full
charlie wow about this whiteboard
[Music]
this goes here and this goes here but
like this has to be removed what if is
over here that's timeless upside down
and this is also upside down because
this is a tv literally koi is doing your
jobs for you i'm just letting you guys
know that inherently these tie in
together this is a conversation that app
follows this this starts in the summer
goes into the fall and then dips into
christmas this is six months yes yes
this is theoretically over the course of
a month yeah a couple days
who knows so this goes here this could
be before anything yeah don't have a
time on that well if we look at like
weather patterns maybe uh oh no
because so this happened this happens
at the end of far from home is where it
begins right that was a summer time 2024
and it takes us into like 2025
and this right is the beginning of
school year kind of implied yeah we'll
imply that's well we don't even know if
it's the beginning of the school year
because they're applying because he got
into college which is simultaneous with
them applying to college conceptually
but this could be later or is this the
next year
because they're all going to 25 oh my
god
i know what you mean they're both going
to school at the same time but i do
think this is a year later but i only
say that off of watching what marvel is
they celebrated it could be the same
like it is back to you
and ned and bruno the same age yeah
chad tell us if you know what year miss
marvel is
when does it mubarak have yeah in 2025
and 20 grand
i'm trying to think of all the things
theoretically they could like play
against each other in sports right we
know this happens a couple of please
after end game and this happens after
that in eternals there's that line like
we have seven days to save the world
basically right i don't know someone had
a chance at like seven days after and
game but i don't think it's like that
close actually that seems extreme we
know it's 2023 still i think this is
here
okay chunky it's like summer time
and it's in 2024
is it yeah sure yeah so
is that simultaneous with like before
hawkeye it should be it should be before
spiderman because this is definitely
fall leaning yeah okay so they have the
rings
are not a goat you are not a goat that's
what it's all about what if we're proud
of you um i honestly think these are
simultaneous uh let's do it for now
right there well because think about it
if they're all applying to school unless
this is a year apart it could be you
know
but we would have no indication
do we know i don't think eternals
do we hear those after shang cheer or
before shang chi because they're talking
about
no they don't talk about the same guys
do we think captain marvel 2 really
takes place in 2026 then because miss
marvel meets captain marvel there so i
don't think they'd said it a year after
spider-man if they're gonna have a
sequel because otherwise you're playing
with three years of continuity because
you're spreading from 20th 23 to 2026 if
that sequel takes place after miss
marvel which it has to because she has
her powers a lot of people in that chat
are saying miss marvel is 2026 which
seems i don't think it's in the future i
think it's 2024. i think it's
simultaneously i think 2025. i thought i
thought kevin feige did address what
year it truly was in miss marvel but i
could be completely wrong i also am
still off about eternals i don't think
this is correct also spectrum here gets
her powers and she's going to be in the
sequel to this here right she's the
third well and then well yeah she's the
third but i think her she now knows how
to use her powers by then so i think the
later the better but they wouldn't hold
her for three years you know if that's
if the secret is 2026
i don't know what what she's doing for
three years she's just working in space
what if and loki don't deserve to be on
the timeline because they're just
they're beyond time they're outside
they're beyond time yeah
it's not fair to even put them on the
board um these are the only two ones we
can be certain of because they've
addressed it so much right we know this
for sure
this is what your website should look
like marvel yes please chaos disney plus
this is what we'd like also like
when doctor strange wins america chavez
is like how does spider-man like webs
they come off his butt and doctor
strange's like yeah i don't know i have
no idea because the the spell happened
so there's no way this happens before
hot guy yeah no i will not allow it
someone brought up a good point they
said do you really think kamal is the
same age as peter parker there's no way
but isn't peter a senior going into high
school i mean college because at mit
yeah yeah yeah but isn't kamala a year
younger than bruno oh no he she's a he's
a junior she's a freshman she no they
say that she's they say that she's a
software and he's and he's also just
going to uh and he's hardly a problem
so she'd be a year or two younger than
peter and it's just for the summer yeah
oh yeah so that tracks
so it could be the same year it could be
i think we told them yeah i really think
this is definitive to me
i love this this is an ink not pencil
i think uh what we can take away from
this at the end of the day is the fact
that like
their timeline is shaken they have wrote
something before they they ran before
they walked how did you think about it
have a meeting about it someone write it
down please do you guys think our board
looks a little bit okay also why can't
every marvel movie start out with
the date and the time oh there's how it
would be there's some detective work in
the chat rachel says driving agent new
jersey is 17. so if she's 17 peter would
be like late 17. she could be getting
her learners which would be 16 yeah that
tracks more for herself well you're no
because she's taking the test when
you're doing the learner's permit you
don't need to take tests that's true
you're learning okay because i graduated
at 17 and we also don't know how many
times she failed it right yeah oh that's
true because like one guy was like oh i
feel like three times but there's no way
she and peter are the same i think
peter's a year older yeah peter's older
than her because he's actually she's
definitely older than her because he's
getting the ged at the end of no way
home and yeah that and he's in high
school and like he's finishing it yeah
uh yes so he's probably 18 she's
probably 16. well he blipped for a while
right chrissy says peter arrives at the
sink someone else please my eyes arrives
at the sanctum and knowing home in
september october based on the new
new dark uh
outside and the halloween decor in the
donut shop you have to be right before
hog yeah we're all i agree with that
yeah we've talked about that on the
channel too yeah lord ryan says ms
marvel mentions 2025 a couple of times i
like that uh can i see this really cool
yeah they say
uh patrick says no way home takes linole
that's not it it's go up go up no way
home sorry
that's the most no way home takes place
directly after far from home which takes
place directly after end game
god i think that's right well far from
home there's some time that has happened
since end game because
the events event game kind of happened
in the spring and then right and like
yeah it's been a few months i think not
you guys aren't wrong in the chat saying
loki is after end game fight you
confirmed that last year no that is
completely true but we're just saying in
the light of them they're outside
they're not allowed to be on like an
actual timeline but the actual death of
he who remains doesn't yeah it is a
moment which causes the doctor strange
thing it's a real moment
it seems kind of weird enough to make a
timeline for a series that has no
timeline yeah does that make sense just
like especially with spiderman
homecoming messing up the time limit
they set that date and then they're like
oh we're so sorry later and they're like
five years later they put it in print
too so it's etched in the movie and
you're like no you know we need to do
this
we need to do this for uh star wars
oh boy i just like to imagine
i still like to imagine the premiere of
homecoming uh kevin feige is there
sitting down with his popcorn that like
five years later pops up and he's just
like
blows up his hands and starts texting
like we've got it calls
uh and yeah just we're still waiting for
like where she hulks yeah black panther
too
and i think she-hulk has to take place
after end game because she doesn't start
with a date and a time
frankly we're all lost because the
chongqi events i think
imply that's before she-hulk because of
how that's the yeah
because yeah because in the trailer
banners banners back double arm in it
well he yeah
yeah it's before it's definitely yeah
she-hulk is before
because he's fuller
he's got his arm in a sling yeah he's
still slinged down so you're thinking
wait heels i think okay explain yourself
because in shanghai he's got a cast on
which occurs because the events of end
game yes in she-hulk he has two arms
and i also think that the events of miss
marvel light spoilers for the storyline
if you haven't watched any of the three
you gotta watch it i'm so sorry if
that's the case i do think shield is
going to be defending against kamala's
law which is the thing that's going to
be affecting the young avengers which
they're being formed throughout the mcu
so i think what's happening is we're
going to see after the events of civil
war don't go through everything fell
apart and mistaken government officials
that wanted to regulate superheroes now
trying to regulate children and that's
going to lead to jennifer walters being
our first superhero attorney regulating
what it means to be a hero again in a
new way someone's got to kill me
someone's got to kill these kids
put your money where your mouth is kill
these you want to get nuts yeah
let's get the brothers in here kill this
the vulture just comes in he's like you
want to get nuts
hey speaking of vultures we want to
thank our sponsors today and landscaped
they're getting rid of that vulture nest
below the waistline because they're
rolling out their best and biggest
ultimate hygiene bundle yet the platinum
package 4.0 uh bandscapes is the leader
in blo below the waist grooming and uh
now you can trust them with the rest of
your body join the four million men
worldwide who dress landscape by going
to manscape.com for 20 off uh plus free
shipping with the code break room uh
their platinum package 4.0 is the
biggest bundle they've ever offered
giving you a bulk discount on
landscape's top products uh it's a
one-stop shop for the man who deserves
it all uh this package has everything
you need for your daily hydro root
daily hygiene routine with the leaf
products
from this this product has everything
this product has everything oh you'll
find their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed
whacker ear nose trimmer ultra premium
body wash ultra premium two in one
shampoo plus conditioner ultra premium
deodorant crop preserver anti-chafing
ball deodorant crap reviver ball spray
toner we gotta fix these balls clear
that's one for that one's for you
anti-shave chafing boxes and the shed
travel bag to hold your goods while
traveling all of this and more can be
yours get 20 off plus free shipping with
code break room at manscape.com that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com uh use code break room
unlock that br big groomed energy with
manscape and remember when you trim the
hedges the tree stands taller um
you just told them what the actual
script that's the real one that's the
real one folks
check out that platinum package 4.0 and
thank you for manscape for sponsoring us
on the break room this week i think
you've enjoyed everything we've done uh
we also want to remind you that new
rockstars is going to be appearing live
in austin texas keeping it weird as part
of the rtx austin 2022 podcast festival
july 1st through the 3rd uh if you've
ever wanted to see some of the awesome
new rockstars host in person now's your
chance uh you can save on your ticket if
you would like to go uh click on the
link in the description and use promo
code new rockstars uh we hope to see you
all there we'll have a lot of fun it's
gonna be a live show very different from
what you see on the channel trivia
prizes tons of interaction there's a lot
of other great podcasts there there's
different ticket options but use our
link use code new rockstars all one word
and get a discount uh and we really hope
to see you there
happy birthday ernest happy birthday
while he's gone uh knowing he's watching
is he watching thomas you better be
watching you jerk
better be joking uh eat a chocolate
covered raisin sprinkle turd you cruel
luffing movement coaching white walking
lovely human we didn't even have to do
anything
hey in honor of tonda it's time for
mandatory
[Applause]
hey guys here's another headline for you
snuck into the mandatory fun uh chris
pratt says his super mario brothers
voice is unlike anything you've heard in
the mario world
okay that doesn't make me feel what does
that mean uh and the director's been
very much like this is going to be
respectful to
mario's italian heritage you know who
wasn't respectful to italian heritage
tom hanks
starlight
yeah i mean tom hanks is allowed to do
an italian accent why isn't chris pratt
logic do you want us mario uh so we were
so smitten with this headline like what
is a mario you've never heard before
like it's me mario it's me
mario uh so i think each of us should
pick a character from the mario universe
for this mandatory fun and let's give uh
uh a line reading give what is what is
this character you've never is make
choose a character and make them sound
like
you've never heard them before
that's a good one okay i've got one you
got one here's my here's my vision right
princess peach has been spending too
much time around toads right so she's
developed somewhat of an inflection a
toad-esque inflection
so i think she'd sound something like
this uh daschle please turn my mic down
this is gonna be unbearable
it's gonna be terrible and also uh i've
heard your r2d2 impression it sounds
vaguely like it i'm gonna do a toad
impression and it's gonna sound like
a
i baked you a cake
i'm so sorry i'd be like let bowser have
one second she's in the right castle not
this one she's in whatever castle she
needs to stay in yeah stay home
don't you dare come out um i was also i
was i was gonna do toad and i think um
in the new toad fashion
um instead of that like
like instead of that voice it'll be more
like
hey peach
i can't keep going all over okay the
kingdom for you baby i'm gonna have to
stay here i'm gonna have to look over
the crops our baby our children this is
good
i like this smoothie smoothie
sexy turkey
i like that and that's my that's how i
think they would take time oh okay i
like that so uh you know yoshi's my guy
and uh yoshi's green which makes me
think is my home city of boston and i'd
like to imagine
a street wise yoshi like uh why the
[ __ ] this guy always on my [ __ ]
back this [ __ ] guy i'm just trying to
be a [ __ ] dinosaur over here
just really harassing my mother and
causing a lot of [ __ ] problems and
i'm sorry to boston um
hey yoshi where did you get those shoes
these [ __ ] kicks kid my mom brought
these for my [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] kids this yoshi has a
tight five definitely 100 this guy can
run some goodness
i'm trying to marry that
women always be shopping
women be shopping he comes out and he
definitely doesn't want his friend to
show up because he's better than this
he's like if i see you here again i'm
gonna kill you kid i'm gonna kill you uh
i guess uh i i could do a i could see a
new bowser right we're gonna have jack
black as bowser in this which sounds
really fun i like that man
often played for jokes but i would like
like a dark
really evil bowser who's just like
mario oh i have suffered at the feet of
your insolence for far too long
i will destroy this mushroom kingdom
before i let you have another ounce of
it
listen to me mario i will skin you alive
and watch
as i feast on luigi
and he eats luigi
and you wonderful breakers out there
your roomies you really pushed us over
the 200 mark thank you so much we owe
them more we're on a roll with
impressions all right we should just
keep doing them here
don't forget we're at 200 so add in bed
oh in bed at the end
okay you have to do it okay
make a video what you want oh we gotta
i already looked i didn't know what to
do with this dab okay
these are hard brandon you chose hard
ones sorry
okay
here we go
you wanna you wanna think on it in a
second oh yeah give me a sec
i i like i like when we guess that's i
like that game
so i'm not gonna do the
more modern interpretation i'm going to
do what i think my interpretation will
be i'm gonna go classic
nature has given us all the pieces
required to achieve exceptional wellness
and health but has left it to us to put
these pieces together in bed oh
you see what i did there
i heard it
you know what i think i saw the first
letter and i think it gave it away so
just just to you it's just you i saw i
know exactly what is it it's not like
the head shot
there's not time to talk slow he's got
places
yeah you do yours
if you do what you're always done you'll
get where you're always gone and then
that's a mickey mouse oh
mickey mouse mickey mouse all right i've
actually tried to do this impression
before it's oddly difficult really
difficult
when you change your thoughts no
remember to change
are you doing great you're doing great
okay i want to hear her impression
remember to also change the world what
does that laugh
oh it's winnie the pooh
you know that's kind of like promoting
yeah moaning myrtles
and diagrams
and diagrams
like this yeah yeah that is true i saw
you under the water it was the giggle
hey i wanted to be known right now i am
not an actor first like two people on
this show okay here's here's my it's not
a good voice it's not a good voice for
this one i apologize
i realized this was a hard one to do i
don't know what i was saying here we go
if you can't you must if you must you
can in bed
that's a superhero
superman
superman do you want to try winnie the
pooh uh yeah thank you
oh oh boy that's julia childs
the julian childs if you can't you must
if you must you can
in bed
well it's also because you're trying to
make your cheeks bigger because he's a
fat oh
uh we do want to thank our super chinese
for getting us over that 200 mark uh
angelica
goliadano coming in there loving the
energy just trying to push you over 200
thank you so much and you did uh sergio
gutierrez come to costa rica you can
stay at my place that doesn't sound
suspicious at all
uh just me no worries anna you're doing
a great job i love all the content you
guys put out bless you
uh lieutenant smash sending in a super
chat given the spiritual slash quasi
horror slash paranormal themes of the
mcu phase four neil gaiman should
definitely write a movie or series
before the phase ends i would say that
but netflix finally gave them the yeah
finally sandman's real life august i
don't know and we missed poppies who
says i love you all that said a good cos
mcneil gaming experience would be a hell
of a thing uh j master said uh on the
latest episode of miss marvel it
references the fit ten rings showing in
the tomb of kamala khan great grandma
getting the bang uh the bengal yeah we
saw like in that episode that the ten
right that was the ten rings
symbol on the floor of that weird temple
where there was the blue hand of maybe a
cree i don't know they don't want to say
but like why the thing that bothers me
is why is that arm still there how long
has it been there for and if it's creed
that definitely does tie into captain
marvel 2 which we're leading to so it
kind of works yeah but how long has that
happened there yeah maybe they don't
okay
we don't know biology yeah i don't know
biology
uh here for the cookie sand i don't know
if it's blasting me to promote another
channel here yep it is
they mentioned another channel my brain
doesn't even see it i'm like westworld
doesn't like anything at all to me uh
zest13 saying motivate me baby you can
do it get after it yeah
we roasted tonda angelico goldiano also
saying next headline
put it on a shirt put it on a shirt uh
fray girl hey koi franco's got a pop
quiz for you oh free girl hot shot what
issue and comic did deathstroke first
appear in and why uh teen titans number
two written by george perez illustrated
i mean it was marv wolfman and george
perez i switched artists and illustrator
and he appeared uh he's the main foil
he's the main villain so he showed up to
be a unifying villain to bring the teen
titans together and later inspired
deadpool i'm turning on is that for real
i don't know if anyone else is turned on
they just got hot in here
sorry i was pop quizzed my guy he
would
was
like
okay
comic book shop like in my pull list and
it's got four things in it and the other
dude's got like 20. oh no i'm that guy i
read 70 comics a week how do you
remember which issue it was
because it wasn't the first issue
because they needed to unify to fight
him in the second issue so yeah and it's
george perez and marvin because they're
icons i did george perez's retirement
tour we lost george recently and i went
on tour with him to do his last cons it
was really beautiful
did you do it i did his last appearances
yeah did you
kill george oh no no
he was a nice man he got to survive
you're like this will be huge
the the true nerd boy why do you keep
calling this my farewell tour you just
don't you win
we're in good hands all right few men
are as nice as george perez what an icon
that's why i know that one very well and
he's fantastic you should have never
asked that question for a girl everybody
in the chat is thirsty and it is friday
i'm just uh
if it is friday
we're ready for it diver's also saying
happy friday first time i get to say see
you live we're happy you're seeing us
live we hope you're still here hey hit
that like button if you haven't already
huh uh theodore harrison marvel studios
will have a panel on sdcc going to be an
interesting summer are they going to
have a panel at comic con did they say
they were going to i think uh kevin
feige mentioned something about it
because someone in the chat said kevin
feige just meant uh said it was like
breaking news
because they had said that we're out
yeah we got d23 we don't need you know
who else is gonna have a panel who bob's
burgers oh bob's burgers did you guys
see frankie last night he did you
spotted him even
that's how you see him
with the thunderbolt through it oh so
those hats are like a goal of mine i
want to have anything else
six of them from doing the like the el
capitan
they give those one hats so i want to
get them all i want a kevin feige closet
of just hats
okay okay well we caught up on our super
chats and we've had such a fun time
today uh i don't know if we have time
for oh we don't
you guys agreed with our mcu timeline 60
39
of you said no so
it really is i don't know what that
means all of these quotes are three
paragraphs there i thought i put some
short ones
look at his paper that would have been a
fortune cookie
a shorter one cheese louise thank you i
don't like that
i don't know
excuse you i think the game oh that is
true i made the game oh man okay okay
the power of roster
is the ability to generate a reeling of
certainty in your health
when ruffin and the arrival where are
you
in bed
can i put mine back i think i'll be
raising the dog from the jetsons of
course that robot dog from the jets who
solves mysteries yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was good
again yeah it's not easy yeah yeah that
was an accident i was like i don't know
she likes reggie
this is the easiest character okay but i
cannot do it save my life let me try and
it's because i can't do accents oh yeah
i'm really bad at accents
um
oh i don't even you want to try it
you're you're an actor you're an actor
i just you know how to get into it
though
i can't do accents well okay actually
that's something you say
you go here i'll get you into it donkey
thank you let's feed into it don't be
developed success i can't do it
success from failures discouragement and
failure are two of the surest stepping
stones to success
choose life
okay uh
uh oh i've heard this one on tick tock a
lot let's see if i can channel it
success is not final fail this is not
going well failure is not fatal it's the
courage to continue the counts winston
churchill
hmm
actually can i i might get my characters
mixed up i think i won't
the okay thing that's keeping you from
hitting what you want is the story
you keep telling
me this this duck is having trouble with
this duck struggle yourself
that's keeping you from getting what you
want
nixon sorry you keep something oh god
it's been all over the table okay this
is okay it's hard to do the catch this
is mine but i get a prop for it
again okay okay oh i saw this one when i
was cutting them up i was like that's
hard we'll see if you can guess this one
folks okay here we go here we go
it's what you practice in private that
you'll be rewarded for in public
john malkovich a scarlet witch yeah
right
well scarlet witchy oh i thought you
said john malcolm
which why would you put that in
the man okay
you guys in the chat did get it right it
was daffy duck oh but i cannot do it to
save my life there's a little mad hatter
in there i thought i was like oh yeah
the candy king or whatever from freaking
uh
wreck-it ralph started to come out too
uh we did get a super chat with that
breaking news that during thor eleven
thunder premiere kevin feige firm
barbara will be at holding a hall h
panel at san diego comic-con comic-con
must have begged him to show off well
i'm thinking he's gone they moved their
d23 to september in august they actually
have more time so i think they're going
to announce some stuff and then they're
gonna have stuff to show with their own
they're gonna throw out they're gonna
give a little teaser some pennies and
then like by the way philippians
then then you gotta boost up your d23
membership nothing like hall h with
marvel though like that truly is
something worthwhile
all these people are standing in line
all day again in the hallway uh and then
finally another super chat from
thanksgiving uh movie fanboy uh coin
look at you go living your best life i
can't believe you were in lowell
recently right near me you've got a
stalker
all the massachusetts and family time i
smelled right now today just finished
work hey movie fanboy we're glad you
finished work and we're so glad you all
joined us today on the break group thank
you so much to coy and anna and jessica
for all being here today check out the
boys underground up on the channel soon
we got some other videos up on the
channel eric and jessica had their
reactions live fresh from last night uh
thank you so much for joining us this
week we hope you had a great time come
back on monday and be part of the break
room again we love you all breakers we
love you super trash we love you roomies
uh have a great friday and don't forget
to scream uh we'll see you next week